this week on quadriga eastern
enlargement big EU big success on May
1st 2004 the EU welcomed ten new
countries into the fold the
Mediterranean island states Cyprus and
Malta as well as eight former East Bloc
nations for the new countries EU
membership promised economic growth and
prosperity but membership also brought
challenges many countries experienced
large-scale outflow of skilled labor and
had to implement costly regulations on
farming and Industry the old EU member
states feared an influx of cheap labor
could undercut wages what's the picture
now 10 years after EU enlargement and
does the EU have a solution for the
growing popularity of Euroskeptic
right-wing populist parties your host
this week melinda crane hello and
welcome to quadriga ten years later can
we still view EU enlargement as a great
success that's what we want to talk
about today with three people who follow
events in Eastern Europe very closely
and it's my pleasure to welcome Katerina
stock poses she works at the University
of Southern Denmark
she's a Polish origin and she previously
headed to Central and Eastern European
Department at the German Council on
Foreign Relations a very warm welcome to
you and Judy Dempsey is with us she's
senior associate at carnagie Europe and
also editor-in-chief of strategic Europe
as a journalist for the Financial Times
she reported from Eastern Europe and
Germany and headed the papers Jerusalem
Bureau she's a regular contributor as
well to the International New York Times
and finally my pleasure to welcome
Michel derma he is senior correspondent
at the German daily de velde
he's a renowned historian and has taught
in Germany the US Canada and its several
European universities and for many years
he served as political adviser to the
German Chancellor a very warm welcome to
you as well
until recently Eastern enlargement has
been seen as one of the --use biggest
successes but Judy Dempsey can we still
regard it in that light given what is
taking
place now in Ukraine yes even more so
and of course it's going skepticism
about enlargement but the EU enlargement
has actually conscious what some believe
given the new member states that a big
number that joined in 2004 they have
given them a kind of psychological
political and economic security without
enlargement there would have been very
very bad shape during this Ukraine
crisis Richard Roma there is of course
widespread acknowledgement now that
NATO's Eastern expansion was problematic
and perhaps also a true provocation to
Russia can we see the --use eastern
enlargement in an analogous light no
it's slightly different but not entirely
different we used to think for first ten
years after the end of the cold war that
EU enlargement it's not expansion its
enlargement that EU enlargement would be
acceptable to everybody not only those
countries that pay but also those
countries who are being excluded or who
have to stay outside meanwhile we've
understood with the help of mr. Putin in
the Kremlin that we have gone too close
for Russian for the Russian case to
close to Russia to the lines to the
bears den and we have to rethink the
reality in the theory of international
law Ukrainians and all other neighbors
of Russia can do what they want in
practice this is a little dangerous and
even the EU sort of intervenes massively
in
those in the lives of countries that
want to join we are making prescriptions
sometimes they're being followed like in
Poland sometimes they are ignored like
in Romania or Bulgaria so we do change
the shape of things and we do it because
we are on the good side of history and
the others are on the poor and losing
side of history so we feel we are
justified but we have to be a little
more careful
katarzyna stock wasn't let's get that
polish perspective it's your country of
course that's often meant when people
say NATO Eastern expansion was
problematic NATO is NATO eastern
enlargement you're absolutely right we
try to avoid that expansion word that
NATO eastern enlargement was a problem
because it pushed into Poland and that
that had at least indirectly been
promised to Russia that that would not
happen in terms of the --use Eastern
enlargement would you say that people in
Poland viewed that very much as an
either/or choice we are choosing the
West and turning our back on Russia on
the east in Polish case I would say
definitely yes the eastern Atlanta was
successful and majority of the
population says yes we have decided to
be a part of Western European culture
center Valley essentia we took this
decision after a breakdown of the coming
years of the socialist bloc 89 and
behind this decision were consequences
as well consequences shorted economic
shortage and polish people knew that
they have first to give something give
up something and perhaps lose a little
bit of an economic power to get
something some years later and this is
what didn't work in other countries for
example in Hungary or what we
observe 9 in Bulgaria and in Romania and
I'm very much agree with you that you
say it yes that analyzing the crisis now
in the Ukraine and what happens between
a crane and Russia we can say that
because of this conflict we can say that
Eastern enlargement was successful
because we have achieved like a common
plan what we have to do how do we have
to react there's two points here Poland
didn't turn their back on the east this
is very very important and as soon as 25
25 years today Paulette is celebrating
its its its liberate its libera libera
lism from communism and the first
strategic decision it made was to reach
out to Ukraine its mortal enemy even as
much as Russia and ever since Poland
joined the truth in the EU 2004 it's
made a conscious effort to use its EU
membership to reach out to be a ruse to
reach out to Moldova to and above all to
reach out to Russia and they they were
using its strengthen the West as a kind
of an avid as an avenue not to leave the
others behind it's been a it's been a
fantastic strategic choice it hasn't
succeeded because it didn't get enough
support from the other EU members yes
but why this choice do you think perhaps
that because polish state was afraid of
the big Russian neighbor so of course
this is one very important point for the
decision to support the crane and pillar
Russia's well I remember when professor
Karen Mac my venerable colleague was
foreign minister that was the time when
the real decisions were made in Gary
mech and Gary Mac made it a very strong
point that there had to be an opening to
Russia that he was very much aware of
the fact that we should be very careful
to sort of turn the face of Russia
towards Asia and I don't
we followed enough of that kind of
enlightened polish approach yeah just
one I think I picked up one thing the
ambiguity of the Polish membership
because Poland I mean is it's a middle
sized member of the EU now with enormous
influence and it's interesting Russia
and Russia my interpretation that Russia
wants Belarus and Ukraine particularly
as their buffer zone against the
democratization and the civil society of
the EU her as Poland actually wants ble
Russia and Ukraine inside the EU as
their kind of buffer zone except against
Russia so in that sense is a very
interesting competitive game going on
which is not entirely pre-seasons
inside the EU but I think the Polish
strategic goals were set out very early
on yeah you're right and this is what
were so many times forgotten in Western
Europe and when they present like the
Polish point of view and why Poland
suppose below Russia and Ukraine and
this is not only because of democratic
values and because of solidarity but
this is because of this tragic
geographical meaning of a position
Polish position between East and West
and because at polish Poland is afraid
of the Russian big neighbor let me take
us to a somewhat related but also
different point when we're asking
ourselves is Eastern enlargement the
success that it is often said to be one
of the arguments often made by
proponents is look it has helped the
countries of Eastern Europe democratize
it has kept them on a path of peace and
democracy yet mr. Omer when we look
ahead to the EU elections pending at the
end of May we are hearing predictions
that we are going to see the biggest
returns to far-right Euroskeptic and
xenophobic parties ever in EU history so
is this also a claim with which we need
to that we need to view with somewhat
more skepticism
I think the skepticism has to be taking
various
indeed and the the future of the EU is
not only about enlargement it may well
be about falling apart when you think
about Britain I think it would be a big
disaster if Britain were to leave the EU
as a result of that pending referendum
that possible referendum in the next few
years so that is a real concern as a
very big concern for this country
because it within the EU we have we have
we don't share the same philosophy we
the Germans share the same economic
liberal neoliberal philosophy with the
Brits but not was France let alone Italy
and and the rest of the southern rim so
the Brits would would not mind if the EU
were simply to become a free trade zone
and not much more whereas Germany has
pushed for deeper integration well we
are now having second thoughts I
remember and that at the time when we in
the worked in the chancellor's office we
never specifically pointed out what kind
of ever closer Union we meant it
wouldn't have been very wise because it
would have opened the
a kind of contradiction between the
French and the Germans and a lot of
others we didn't mean the same thing and
now we are having the financial of the
euro crisis the euro has divided Europe
instead of uniting Europe we have big
problems because the euro and the
banking Union can only be saved by ever
closer integration and while the
majority of the people says enough is
enough
we don't want the Commission to
intervene in our bathrooms bedrooms
living rooms everywhere day and night 24
hours seven days a week we don't want
that we don't want in Germany to live
without our beloved federalism and we
don't want to live under a kind of
centralized Anonymous bureaucracy
overpaid and over here so there are
countervailing sources let me ask Judy
you of course with great knowledge of
Britain would you say that the
possibility that Britain could vote to
leave the EU that this does reflect a
kind of backlash related to a too strong
to Brussels too strong and also too much
meddling and also perhaps to the fact
that the EU project was pushed too far
to us it is surprising that Britain ever
agreed to join the EU frankly because
the Soraa skepticism really run so deep
I mean it was a Conservative government
Prime Minister Edward Heath who brought
Britain into the it was a fantastically
radical revolutionary decision and now
this it is a huge amount of skepticism
it's it runs deep it's reached a height
now for two reasons it's not the
bureaucracy in the EU this is totally
exaggerations and the tabloids it's the
lack of a leadership by the Labour Party
and the Tory party especially the truth
the Conservative government about the
benefits of Europe
this is the first thing and secondly the
Brits the British or rather the English
the Scots are different matter and the
relative matter the English don't
understand and European leaders accept
Angela Merkel tells them privately they
don't understand that the place has to
be in Europe because America is not
going to remain interested in Europe
Third Point Europe Europe's foreign
policy and security policy is nothing
without the Bish's component and British
Armed Forces and defence room and just
one thing
now with the huge cutbacks in the
British Armed Forces the British
military cannot do it alone anymore the
old days are over and the the English
public and the English media
particularly must embrace this idea of a
European Asst we are nothing without
Britain and this Europe is so weak in
view of the weakness of the
transatlantic relationship and Mileena
it's not only it's not only the
referendum that may go one way or the
other you keep the United Kingdom
Independence Party we'll probably make
it impossible for the Tories to win
outright majorities ok let us now talk
about that right-wing element which as I
said we may see seeing very significant
returns in the upcoming EU elections
katarzyna stock was a perhaps many of us
remember the famous polish plumber
discussion the idea that after eastern
enlargement suddenly Western European
countries would be flooded with Polish
laborers like Polish plumbers looking
for work Medina if you really need a
plumber polish by garyun god knows from
the moon
you are very grateful when he comes out
there hugely enlarged immigration as a
result of a stern largeman has it come
to pass did people flood out of Poland
after they were able to do so after 2014
yes and no and yes Polish people and not
so many Czech people but sure later on
people he started to immigration to this
is very difficult a very important point
for Eastern enlargement a new
immigration and a new labor market and
working migration is something that
happens until today
and to some think is a very important
point of a daily life in Europe in the
whole Europe but I did
yes but it's different and now we have
to dense the distinct between migration
of qualified people non qualified people
because why and because after migration
started up perhaps before the migration
started first first appeared and above
all how dispersed and propaganda was
presented in Western European media and
in Germany newspapers and German
television they started to present new
migration big migration movements out
people who want to yes take away jobs
from from the other German Center nada
worse than European and it didn't
happened yes and five years later when
we analyzed the numbers above all from a
border region this is very important
because this first appeared above all in
the border region where this direct
migration started to develop and sure
where the Polish plan started to move to
the German site of the German Polish
border and what these numbers showed us
that the rarity was different that
imagination and turfers in the media so
it was a little bit like a propaganda
but is propaganda less until today
venture today we can compare this
perspective this analysis referring
Bulgarian and Romanian let me just throw
a few numbers out there I know you want
to address that point Judy but here's a
few numbers 1.6 million Romanians
left Romania that is 7.2 percent of the
population
that's a significant number 1.3 million
poles that's about 3.4 percent of poles
the big question of course though is
first of all where are they going what
kind of jobs are they taking are they
displacing workers and then also are
they eventually returning to their home
countries what do we know about that
June and very interesting and first of
all because of the special I don't want
to make it so technical there was a ban
on the poles and the Hungarians and
Czechs coming to Germany after seven
years up to seven years after the U and
enlargement now these these workers they
were skilled and unskilled students
student students this is 50 this was the
mecca Europe this was the freedom to
travel the freedom to work enshrined in
the in the in the full movement of free
rooms of the EU they went to my country
I'm Irish I'm emigrated they went to
sweet it's fantastic they went to Sweden
they went to Great Britain they went to
Belgium they went of France France
discovered the real quality of Commerce
and they went Ireland and of course
Scandinavia and generally also recently
they were met with open arms not only
did they fill a huge labor shortage but
they reinvigorated the schools and the
universities and a way of life they
brought a way of life a kind of cultural
identity which was eroding in part of
Ireland especially in the church
actually and in Britain the other very
important point remittances they sent
the money home and either they saved in
Britain and maybe they bought apartments
but they sent the money home for
education for apartments to build up
their own kind of little nest and this
is always forgotten and despite what
people Kipp says this awful far
right-wing party in in Great Britain
that the Polish contribution to the
economy has been enormous but so what
accounts for the disconnect Michelle
Sherma if if the picture is as positive
as we've just heard from Judy why do we
have far-right parties all of over
Europe claiming that immigrants are
stealing jobs that they are a terrible
threat and that the EU essentially is
undermining
economies
people feel alienated from where they
are it's a it's a it's an alienation
it's psychology much more than economy
how it's not hard facts of sociology
labor movement in most cases I think if
you are in trouble and you need a
plumber you don't ask many question but
you put into work wherever it's needed
it's also the result of many many years
in fact decades of national politicians
blaming the EU for things the EU needs
to be blamed for many things but not for
everything and it was a common feature
of German politics that we pitied
ourselves to be the chief treasurer of
the EU and something built up and then
of course in Germany but in particular
the we have in our historical tradition
but also after 1945 or 1949 we have a
fairly balanced domestic system of
running running politics running
business and here the EU bureaucracy the
Eurocrats were seen to get involved in
the most ridiculous detail and that gave
a bad name also whether you Nana's can
be bent more than a certain angle who
cares and all kinds of meddling as you
said was seen and then of course ten
years ago when Bulgaria and Romania they
joined a little later but big area and
Romania were visibly unprepared and why
why they joined or why they were
admitted had to do with balancing
Germany against France and France
against Germany and South against North
it was a cynical game and then people
discovered well we have uninvited guests
and we don't want that it has gone too
far too fast and this is a revolt there
is no sensitivity in Brussels that
history matters culture matters it's all
ticking off certain statistics Catarina
this is not an important question
whether we have a really well developed
migration policy in Europe and this is
very different and you're right that
this first have to do with pictures with
something imagined with serotypes and
prejudices and now let us analyze a
little bit this migration policy and
it's very different and different in
Britain and what you presented is
exactly the perspective that polish
media and Polish people have from
British media and yes British analyse
and assess watch the Polish people alike
this is a positive way of presenting
Polish migration in the Great Britain
it's very different in Germany in
Germany even qualified migration isn't
presented too well enough it's like okay
we have this foreign professors and
scholars at our universities so and so
many percent but it's for example
different from northern European
countries in Sweden in Finland entered
in a mark they're proud because they
have sold so many foreign students enter
professor they presented really like
with proud okay we have more than 50% of
qualified migration from dis and dis and
dis countries it's really very very
different in Europe and this is what I
missed some time referring Germany can I
think the migration is is an issue but I
would see the migration not involving
the EU members but how we're going to
deal with the Middle East which is far
more critical but there's another aspect
which I think that you've been very slow
to recognize and the inability
particularly Romania and Bulgaria to
absorb the struck
and people the young people are leaving
there's a brain drain because of the
lack of opportunities the pervasive
corruption and the kind of wasted time
in making the system more flexible to
keep the people at home and I think this
is a huge problem that some of the
problems are homegrown and that the
Bulgarian domain has been absolutely far
too slow in recognizing that this brain
drain the people were not about like to
talk a bit about the effect of
enlargement on the Eastern countries and
start out by asking you measurement dude
II just meant to mentioned inability to
absorb structural funds but also some
people would say inability to absorb the
kind of or to to practice the kind of
political changes that were expected
particularly in the case of the late
coming Eastern member countries now
again as I said we often say look this
prospect of becoming EU members that put
them on the path of democracy it helped
them to start changing their legal
systems but how far those changes really
gone are Bulgaria and Romania
full-fledged members of the democratic
community as we expect them to be
they're not they are not and democracy
isn't just about going to vote every
four or five years democracy needs a lot
of infrastructure and I don't mean
bureaucratic infrastructure I mean the
state of law reliability of courts
transparency open discussion so it is
this whole set up the institutional
setup and the mentalities of people and
john xxiii this very room a new saint in
his day said you have to give time to
time the politicians and also the
bureaucrats especially the commissioners
there's one Commissioner who has no
other responsibilities than to admit new
countries whether they are fully fit
half it or not fit at all if you do that
you are creating trouble and
you bring in all kinds of misfits and
it's not there was not enough time if
you want to change mentalities and
democracies are about mentality
fundamentally you either need a very
long tradition like in Britain all you
need a shocking experience a traumatic
experience like in Germany and then it
will work but it takes time it takes
decades it doesn't take a month it
doesn't take two or three years it takes
decades and we didn't give ourselves the
time was a devil's advocate might say
then in the end eastern enlargement
practiced too quickly pushed too quickly
actually dilutes the EU zone standards
and that we have seen it embracing
countries that lag very badly on
corruption or if we take a look even at
Hungary which was one of the first
Eastern countries to be admitted hardly
convincing on democracy at the moment
completely agree and very good analysis
of Michelle's DOMA and but I don't
believe in different mentalities said
mentalities are equal about different
traditions and customs but have
something that you will live here you
did it yeah we all right but don't you
think that this results you have
presented and I completely agree Romania
and Bulgaria are not prepared but this
is perhaps in on not only they forth
this is perhaps also our European world
because we didn't express our
expectations enough what we expected yes
and we expected of course not only
economic changes but political changes
and changes referring a large corruption
and so and so on but they were like a
little bit of taboos and political
correctness we didn't express our wishes
and expectations enough and two points
on this and actually now that the fault
of the EU was that once you're in the
pressure is lifted but in fact in the
case of Romanian Bulgaria actually the
pressure has
consistently increased in them to
actually improve judiciary transparency
this is a good thing the index towards
corruption it's it's juicy it's a good
thing too it went far there would've
been far worse out than in I would make
one point this is not the first
enlargement remember Spain and Portugal
after dictatorships and Greece imagine
had they not been brought in this was
the marvelous and this was the marvelous
lever the marvelous and change for these
countries that personally I want to go
back to Greece in a second but it was
after the military coup but I mean it's
remarkable the changes that were made to
Spain and Portugal by bringing them in
the dictatorship was shaken off this of
course a big difference with the
communism because communism was so
totalitarianism invasive did the Spanish
model what happened in Spain was copied
exactly in in Poland because the pain
was so severe yeah yes you see there is
an architectural problem when the wall
came down it was obvious at least for
the German parliamentarians and for the
German government in the early 1990s
something would have to be done we could
not just sit there and watch what watch
what would happen with something had to
be done
poor neighbourhoods had to be brought in
Poland Czechoslovakia and then a concept
was developed called Detroit Lamas paper
and that asked for variable geometry it
asked for a core group of EU experienced
well-to-do homogeneous countries which
would guide the others but with very
long periods of acclimatization it was
not fully sitting on the fence and
folding our arms and doing nothing it
was about an active course but
tailor-made for every country and every
country what happened to that what
happened to that it was put off the
table by Chancellor Kohl because he said
it would be far too complicated and then
we stumbled into widening and more
widening whether this was justified or
less just if
or countries were well-prepared or ill
prepared or not prepared at all Greece
is a wonderful example and on top of all
this we also put the euro currency with
the great illusion that everybody would
be happy to join the most important
financially speak the most important
country is Britain and Britain has not
joined and will not join in any
foreseeable future so I think we got
ourselves into and into a political mess
there was nothing between heaven and
hell hell was outside the EU heaven was
inside the EU and this is the kind of
situation in which political scientists
and economics economists like to talk
about the second best
there was no first best we went with
second best and we got a mess Katerina's
took was it I'd like to again ask about
the countries themselves starting with
your country Poland how would people in
Poland be living if there had been no
Eastern enlargement again second best it
may not be the ideal but how have lives
changed in a way that they how would
they be different yes the things changed
a lot yes politically economically
injure countries in the countryside yes
so I would say in eastern Poland I
compared a little better development in
western Poland this is well developed
part of of Poland because of the big
important stronger German neighbor and
eastern part of Poland underdeveloped
polish countryside with another big
neighbor but not so they had strong but
not economically strong Russian one and
cranial one and Belarusian one but what
was different from Bulgaria and Romania
was the churn different programs
structures programs were introduced in
military after eastern enlargement
education program started to develop
German and English languages program so
it's like anything was prepared for the
enlargement and people really wished
this enlargement and people were ready
to pay something for this to pay
economic price to make first
transformation process and knowing that
10 years later they will get something
better and today we profit from this and
latticed this I think that enlargement
was prepared from psychological point of
view ok slightly different from what I
meant though you know in a way let me
ask Judy as well cuz I know you've just
come back from Estonia
I believe yes um how would you say lives
on the ground the man on the street how
has his life changed in a way that it
wouldn't have been if he had if the
country hadn't been admitted there
would've been highly vulnerable first
dot freshly and secondly there would
have been an enormous pressure on them
by Russia I mean there is a Russian
minority living in Estonia but the
Estonians what is interesting about the
Estonians and it was wonderful being up
there having time to talk to normally
story historians they they are a small
country that need the EU and for them
the EU represents a very special kind of
freedom and independence and above all
of coming home people forget identity
but they have preserved their identity
in in many languages and in many aspects
of how they eat very fascinating cuisine
and how they dress but it is the idea of
that very special independence and
coming home which by the way joining
nation was very special for them as well
this is the first thing secondly I flew
from Tallinn to Frankfurt on the way
back to Berlin the plane was full of
young Estonians going to work in
Stuttgart or southern
Germany highly-skilled going home with
the weekends I'm going to visit the
mobility the flexibility they've taken
it on board and they're very they feel
that they have a certain confidence
we've made it now one last point
curiously the small states at the small
state states that joined in 2004 a very
pro but the Czech Republic doesn't
defend the EU enough well we've got in
now and now we can they don't pull don't
pull the way and also the political the
political debates and a but and some
other issues let me now ask us to turn
to the future because we don't have too
much more time left in our program the
question for me when I hear that coming
home culture who's a European how much
further does it go Mischa Irma if I look
at the EU treaties the EU is defined as
based on freedom democracy equality the
rule of law and respect for human rights
who still needs to be in that club and
where does it stop well history never
ends history never stops
there will be new challenges and people
will get you so it this this is a
generational project this isn't a
project for a quick fix
ticked off somewhere in Brussels
backrooms it's a generation project
under well it will be very beneficial
and hopefully this will yield also some
piecemeal solutions for problems at the
eastern rim of the EU the this is
completely unsettled this is pretty
dangerous it may explode Eastern
Partnership that of course Eastern
Association this is what we were
offering to Ukraine will Ukraine for
example should it be a full-fledged
member of the EU at some point in the
future not not in the foreseeable future
Ukraine is completely unprepared Ukraine
is let it be said so far a failed state
for a number of reasons from emigration
to corrupt Ally
but you there is no base to build on the
EU is a very ambitious project and if
you liked Romania and Bulgaria you will
love Ukraine or white Russia no these
are this is pie in the sky for a very
long time Kadena stock was a Balkans
turkey if we do not give a prospect of
admission to these countries do we wind
up creating a permanent zone of
insecurity and vulnerability on Europe's
eastern flank what would be very
important is to create a zone of
cooperation stronger cooperation and
communication and exchange including
Russia and because it's very important
just important to communicate about our
values and show what is like our common
European bases and our expectations to
the others to become a part of Europe
and if they are not able and not willing
there are other possibilities in the
whole discussion about Ukraine of course
Julie Dempsey in the West there's been a
lot of self-flagellation about the fact
that we didn't do a better job of
presenting this as an and rather than an
either-or situation in terms of Ukraine
Europe and Russia do you think that a
true cooperation with Russia and EU in
this eastern area including Ukraine is
truly possible would Russia wanted
Russia with pick and choose and what
Russia the Kremlin this leadership
doesn't want is the contagion of the EU
values and there's a complete rejection
of the human rights and of the civil
society and of our way of life of other
kind of post modernity this Kremlin the
leadership in Russia does not want this
we can't have that kind of relationship
what we can have on property must have
is
the right to travel we must have the
young people get the scholarships to
work to see how you're functions this is
not an either-or you've got to keep the
door open otherwise we will be building
a new Berlin Wall way to the east of the
EU mr. Maher very short if you would
please looking again toward the future
do we need a bigger younger EU to
compete with rising powers like China
the short answer is yes the very
important question is the role of Russia
and all of this Putin I think is gaining
land and people but he is losing the
future he's losing modernization which
Russia badly needs Russia is over-aged
its Russia is in a bad state thank you
very much to all of you for being with
us today and thanks to all of you out
there for tuning in see you soon